welcome everybody today three podcast
live thank you to Dollar Shave Club quip
and hymns for sponsoring this episode
the a Street podcast god bless you
today's guest oh I forgot to open the
thing today's well today's guest is the
Lord of spice the greatest interviewer
over time generation well I don't know
if we can say all time I don't I would
not I would know get excited I could say
it mate it may be that you become that
the verb because you're young man you
have much more of your good work ahead
of you yeah but you're setting me up I
feel like okay greatest interviewer of
with chicken wings on YouTube not only
get all that out and YouTube complexes
hosts of hot ones the great and
wonderful Sean Evans thank you so much
for being here I appreciate you being
here
so much god bless you thank you for
having me it's an honor I have to say
one of the coolest things we've done in
our career is probably being on your
show that I remember that fateful
afternoon that was a beautiful thing
like in West Hollywood your show has
become this like is so legendary on new
media I think that it's one of the
highest honors I think a lot of people
come from traditional media there's
probably still some who don't know what
the show is
yeah of people who know what it is it's
like yes it has like it has a cult
quality to it for sure for sure
mmm well first of all as the king of
spice and the dude has eaten a Carolina
Reaper twice in multiple times who eats
the hottest sauce in the world on a
weekly sometimes daily basis it's true
eyes conquered the world of heat and a
half how's your butthole doing what hole
is holding up for everybody who's
concerned out there it is just it's
battle-tested it's military-grade it's
never been better you know I've really
it's like it's like somebody getting in
the gym you know what I mean I feel like
I've just built up a superhero butthole
at this time yeah what's your favorite
toilet paper Charmin you know triple-ply
if they had a six ply or 12 ply or 15
ply would be all that in a teamfight
weapon with the book yeah
exactly clogging that tie up every time
always looking for good toilet paper and
so far I haven't found that perfect
white well I feel like too cuz there's
such a range like I don't know what
animal would use some like single ply
public bathroom toilet paper when just
for like another 40 cents you can just
have that quality comfortable spirit I
feel like their only business is on
people who abide by accident-- right
right and I've been there and I'm like
oh wait there's enough stopped at the
corner store to pick up toilet or this
or just offices or hotel have you
noticed no matter how nice of a hotel
you stand it could be a five-star Four
Seasons I don't know oh great they
always have shitty toilet paper it's
like they decided that's the one place
we're all gonna cut the corner and - you
know what drives me insane is that they
always have like nine different types of
face lotion at some places and then they
never have toothpaste but like
toothpaste you can't get that on TSA and
I always have that problem where I'm
like I don't have toothpaste but why
isn't that standard like to paste
toothpaste should be at every how
everyone is going on it's like yeah I
got a riddle it seems like because when
you stay at these nice hotels they they
get like lotion from all these companies
try lotion you can buy some at the front
counter toothpaste hello
there's definitely a void in the
marketplace there we are already
there's a great Eddie Murphy I don't
remember I think was a Murphy he's like
I don't care how [ __ ] up your life is
how poor you are get the two-ply like
you know everybody can afford that to
apply for sure we're this luxury
everyone deserves well before we get
started we made a little tribute tribute
to you well an appreciation of your
spice and vulnerability your super
powers one may say I'm excited so here's
a little tribute so if anyone at home is
not familiar with Sean Evans if that's
possible shame on you
long pause but if you happen not to be
just a big fan like us please enjoy this
video as a tribute and I hope you enjoy
it I'm already into it
[Music]
[Music]
that's why you can do it I'm just a
normal guy there you go wow that's like
something that should play out of loop
at a modern art museum shout out Alex oh
definitely pulling his weight around
here I think there's a little attention
little you see there's a there's an
easter egg in the undershirt is that
what you're gonna point out no no what
the hell do you do I look at you don't
see that you don't see that at Eddie
fresh sure that's at Eddie fresh t-shirt
you see the little peeking out you are
ripping what I was gonna say that he he
you've seen this gag where they make a
wink but they like they just distort it
in Photoshop what he did is he found you
winking another video cropped it out
over your face pretty convincing it was
I fell for that
I was like did I wink but what that
really is meant to celebrate is you're
you're seeming Lea and vulnerability to
spice are you what's the deal do you not
show it are you just do you build a
tolerance to spice what's going on with
you I think that and maybe you could
probably help with this having been on
the receiving end is that when you're
doing the show I think that there's a
responsibility with the interview that
kind of turns you into a superhero you
know you have to like keep the show
moving and like the pace so even if you
are uncomfortable you can kind of get
outside of it the same way you know like
an athlete in a moment of being
exhausted might do something superhuman
or like a mother that sees their child
rolled under a Volkswagen might have
that like super strength to pick up the
car and get them out from being pinned
under the tire you know that makes a lot
of sense
so I think that that's part of it and
then too I think that there's a part of
it that is like I need to show a
strength
a show of strength to you the guest as
sort of a comforting thing you're the
you're the commander who leads the
charge I'm like a shaman yeah exactly so
there's like part of it where you know
if I'm freaking out then maybe you freak
out like if I go on at Bear Grylls a
show and he's like we need to scale this
waterfall and then he's like trying to
do it and freaking out and crying and
stuffed and I'm like I'm not going up
there with him
you know what I mean so like if I'm
freaking out you're not gonna keep going
and part of it you know it's interview
but part of it is like helping see you
through this journey you know that's a
great response that's really powerful I
can keep that going so does that imply
that somehow when the interview is done
that it hits you I think like at this
point now doing it like 110 times over
the last two years and changed there's
nothing that I don't expect you know
what I mean so I think that that helps
and then there was a time early on where
yeah it would like [ __ ] up my day and
maybe like [ __ ] up the day after but now
at this point like if I have a shoot at
like two I could hit the gym at like
5:30 or 6:00 like I am starting to adapt
to a point that like maybe is like
borderline concerning but at least my
life is keeping a better pace and you do
you do any kind of like regulating your
body is there any doctors involved so
going on well I'm almost afraid to check
it out cuz like they'll shut down my way
or something like that but you can't eat
any more spicy food and then it's like
bull now you know and everything better
off just not knowing yeah exactly like
I'd prefer to just not know the time
I'll question if you don't go to the
doctor you can't get can't exactly like
I think the ignorance is bliss and that
respect okay but then to is like I never
really do anything like people give me
like 10 million tips all the time but I
do just kind of ride it out and then at
this point I kind of enjoy it because
you know like as you know there's so
many like calls emails da-da-da-da-da
when you do this and like I can kind of
build in an excuse if I'm like doing hot
ones or like popping a pepper or like
doing one of these shoots where I'm like
no one talked to me for like three or
four hours you know and I'll just go
home I'll blast the AC I'll put on
basketball shorts I'll catch up on some
DVR I'll listen to music and like I've
actually come to appreciate that I can
like play that excuse
like everybody exactly respect exactly
how like they think they have to get you
that line but now there's a trap that
actually sounds great yeah yeah so tell
me about this know you guys so since I
was on the show yeah what was the
hottest one then I'm trying to put it
would that be Blair's Megadeth sauce
with that was the one yeah so so how
does that compare now are you guys still
using Blair's is that like number two or
did you just so from the rotation we
took that out and then we brought back
this new like I was Blair that well
maybe you know I'm probably at some
level but then Blair I feel like no
Blair I've I know Blair through people
like I've never met Blair it's like
loose on the bench man in New Jersey but
I also to think like you know he had
such a run there for a couple seasons
where you know he's like a jersey that
we hang in the rafters like he's retired
he's Hall of Fame like yeah he has like
a statue
outside a stadium you know like his
legacy will live forever um but then
with those sauce is what we did you know
like speaking of the consequences of it
you know like when you do something like
this on a long-term level we were like
looking into you know like the possible
side effects like from a health
perspective and it's like well if you
use natural ingredients then you know
like you actually end up like cutting
that down quite a bit
really so like that was our move like we
had to take the line up and move to you
know more natural sauces was just direct
based or yeah so like a lot of those
like super super hot ones they'll use an
extract or whatever and that's look like
really turns that up so our challenge
with this is like obviously we need to
make a super hot sauce you know like
that's the name of the show but then how
do you do it with natural ingredients so
what we did with this is we hooked up
with our boy and you know I'm like grew
reputation smokin ed curry yeah and we
put them on the phone and we're like
that was our challenge you know like how
do we do this
and what's funny about smoking ed curry
and then these just pepper growers in
general they're all like Architects are
trying to build the tallest building
they're all kind of retained this is
subculture farmers is nuts and smokin ed
curry might be the craziest one of them
all
so he grew the Caroline like better I
mean before he grew the Carolina Reaper
which for years and years was the
Guinness Book World Records have aureus
pepper right notorious pepper yeah and
then what happened is this farmer in
Wales grew a Dragon's Breath chili that
topped the Carolina Reaper but smoke and
IDI is always playing chatter to be
telling me and I'm not even sure if I'm
supposed to share it but [ __ ] it he has
this this this war chest full of peppers
you know he's got aces up his sleeves
that are all hotter than the Carolina
Reaper and he had it even when the
Carolina Reapers gonna be was feeling
bad he was a Larry top him so that he
could just dunk on him right back like
Kobe so the next point in that line was
pepper axe so we're like alright so if
we take pepper axe and then we you know
like we and here's the other thing that
we wanted to do because it's not hard to
make something super spicy you know and
we don't want just a sauce it's like
well you might as well just like teargas
yourself in the face for your eyebrow
yeah so like a culinary challenge isn't
balancing that flavor and then making
something that has a great flavor so
that was our goal that was our challenge
can you really enjoy the flavor of this
you tell me well I want to say at the
end of the show cuz I don't want to ruin
right you're right alright it's actually
chat right we wanted to try this and the
crew wanted to try it so we're all okay
pop the seal some day yes okay nobody's
tried it okay yeah I want to try it I
want to try this all of us are gonna try
to end the show as I'm saying thank yous
but like so tell me compared to Blair's
how much how far have we gone well I
think that like at some point you just
get into the clouds where it's like
you're just you know what I mean there's
not that much separation I think though
like on just biting into it if you have
like Blair's are de bomb which you guys
have bomb is the one I think was it
number eight yeah and a bomb and I
always see it with the guests is always
the one we're like like this one's
[ __ ] up and that's true be the one
that stands out my mind the worst one
right it is it is for sure and it's
because it like it has that just pure
extract and then like very few if any
redeeming quality right
only eating something that's super hot
it also doesn't taste good so it's just
a miserable experience all around so I
think that like having gone through that
or like whatever then this does seem
like a reprieve because at least it
doesn't taste like [ __ ] like
psychologically plus like once you're in
it and maybe you can tell me from like
being on that end and as somebody who's
gone through it a bunch of times I feel
like you know it's not necessarily like
an escalation in the saw like it's kind
of a bell curve like it is you end up
like eating and you're like oh this is
good and then you're like oh this is
getting spicy and then you're like oh I
want to die and then you have like a
couple wings left so it has that like
psychological thing but once you get to
that point like your mouths like so
burnt out you're so like into the show
like you've sunk it into that seat but
it's like fine you might as well get
pepper sprayed like you're not ready and
of course a conditional you're
definitely right once I hit the bomb
because you're like man how can it get
any worse than this but it actually he
doesn't really right yeah you mean then
number nine because I did the last
school too because you have such unique
experience do cuz you just enjoy so that
number nine killed me
mm-hmm but and then the ten was I wonder
if it's worse for you it's way worse
okay I was like the bomb is awful and
then I was somewhat like relief but you
just got yeah that's a very unique
experience
so guys stay tuned we're all gonna hit
you I'm not you have nothing to prove
I'm not gonna have to look it's just I'm
not gonna whatever you want but but I
was wondering what's the difference
the situation is like you know it's like
with Samuel Adams you might have like a
winner ale and then you might have an
Oktoberfest so yeah so we used the
Carolina Reaper yeah they're both pretty
[ __ ] up we put the Carolina Reaper in
one and then the last dab pepper axe and
the other but also because shout out to
the fans thank you to the fans pepper
axe you know coming from smoking head
curry it only grows on one farm and then
now we have this super international
demand he saw I was like so they like
our fans shout out to
drained Lake you know what I mean so
it's like we can't like ever like you
can't make enough as we grow it as we
make it it just disappears
so to like bridge that gap in the
growing season we're like here's the
last AB Carolina Reaper but that is the
you know what we want to do like to us
like making an episode as a creative
process but so is making a hot sauce you
know that I think I think that they're
you know I think that if you asked 10
people side by side we'll do it five
people at the end of that we're gonna do
it world do both all right cool you
don't have to I'm into it by the way the
pepper X is that gonna be the final name
so I think at first it was like we were
like her name to be determined and then
we were like pepper X and we're like
whatever but then now I feel like
everybody knows it yeah right so and I
like it it's like oh it is yeah yeah
it's a pepper X X I was gonna say that
so I had it as a placeholder but now
there'd be like massive confusion um
yeah maybe back in the day he called
pepper X but now that you're hitting the
scene I like the name thank you
it's it's nice old ship it's a yeah and
so but are you implying that this
psychopath who makes these has another
one up his sleeve beyond X and another
one oh my god one in another one and he
he's like eating them right and yeah
he's insane he'll like I've seen him
he'll just be like what are you doing
it'll just be like snacking on Reapers
no nuts
he's about about like he's about the
life genetically altered like how was he
breeding peppers I mean I guess that's
the science that I don't understand
maybe yeah so like I you know it seemed
to me like he'll explain it well like
talk it through but yeah he's like yeah
he's like doing these like crossbreed
like Frankie biology Airmen's
like he he has like a whole interesting
backstory if anybody wants to dive in
who goes I want like aerith's some of
his laundry but yeah he's been a a
Breaking Bad chemist of sorts this whole
life and that of now he's and now he's
channeling that into hot sauce crazy
well alright stay tuned to the end guys
I'm smoking I mean he's the best
so before you develop the show did you
have an affinity for hot foods
oh yeah it's like incidental I mean um
you know like when I was a little kid
you know if the Bears games of my dad
has chips out and salsa I remember being
like like a little kid six seven years
old like going to dip into the salsa my
dad has hot sauce and I'm like salsa but
he's like not in my house so my dad was
a salsa purist and he's like when did
the salsa you got to do real salsa so I
think like an - like by virtue of that
c-minus d-plus parenting like it did
kind of lay the groundwork what we have
today so I've always had that sort of
tolerance but as I say in the show
sometimes like I'm no superhero like I
go through it - you know I really do but
they're back they have soldiers through
what do they say courage is not being
fearless Sean Wow it's confronting your
fears bravely was there ever a point in
your career when you're like you know
what I'm I'm not doing a spicy anymore
I'm [ __ ] done I'm not touching
anything spicy I don't want to see
anything spicy I'm done well I mean
there's like part of you here's the way
I look at it hot ones I'm obsessed with
it and I you know this wouldn't have
happened if I wasn't you know and like
the team around and whatever and we'd
never would have been able to make this
flow cuz it is a super lean team on a
shoestring budget and the fact that and
you would know this you know doing a
celebrity-driven talk show week over
week droppin that [ __ ] at Thursday at
11:00 a.m. like clockwork is you know
that kind of looks easy at a surface
level but you go behind the scenes on
that there's a lot of brutal brutal
that's a lot of rabbits being pulled out
of a hat that's a lot of things coming
together at the last second in order to
make that happen so like yeah there's
some times you're like yeah but I am
obsessed with it like honestly sometimes
I couldn't even like imagine my life
like without this sort of thing and then
it's so important to like so many people
like it really does have a cult
following that I feel like
you know there's a responsibility even
for your audience even when you're kind
of like a need of it you know I don't
know how sustainable that is like the
last two years to like do that I don't
there's no way I can do that for the
next five or the next ten but like right
now you know like even when I have those
sort of like I need a vacation thoughts
that takes me out of that the fact that
like there's somebody at Thursday at 11
a.m. that like looks for that that like
needs that there are couples that make
wings and they eat them together on
Thursday you know like there's so many
people in their cubicles that watched
and laugh or on their lunch breaks or
whatever and like the kids that are
passing it around and I don't think I
can like let them down you know because
I wasn't you know I don't know do you
ever have that like were you like whoa
I'm like [ __ ] yeah sometimes well I well
that's a different color sometimes it
makes me feel it's it's a way I have a
weird relationship with it sometimes
lately because I feel like we've been
doing it so long that I'm I've often
found myself getting burned out so when
I taking breaks I just feel like guilty
about it yeah unable to rest even though
I'm not making videos so I'm like well
mine are just [ __ ] I don't know it's
the whole the whole thing it's a whole
cycle and then you the other side of it
is that you're like well I could just
lose this in a second and then you're
like alright well then think back I'm
like oh well like I was you know that
was like not a good headspace to be
thinking that way because all I do is
like want that back like need that back
so I'm just pardon the pun striking
while the iron's hot yeah I'm just
trying to keep doing that yeah word so
let me start let me go way back
how did you start working with complex
so I was broadcast journalism major but
there's no real like you know you always
have that dream or thought that you
could be on TV but it's not like you can
just like apply - yeah a network and be
like give me a show right so I was
working at a marketing agency as like
doing press releases and stuff and then
at night and on weekends I would take as
many freelance projects from magazines
as I could just to keep my eye of the
tiger you know what I mean because the
job that I was working at the time was
like a little bit of like a soul-sucking
boring job so I was like well I need to
keep like I need to keep my edge so I
take as many of those as I could doing
nights and weekends and then at an
all-star weekend like five
five years ago I had all these
interviews with like 2 Chainz and John
Wall Dwight Howard Kareem abdul-jabbar
like all these things that were supposed
to be print interview situations and it
was right when complex launched their
YouTube channel so they're like oh we
need to program this thing out we just
need videos to get this plane off the
ground like can we put your interviews
on camera and I was like [ __ ] yeah I
wanted to be in front of the camera well
at that point in my life like an on
camera 2 Chainz interview would be like
the coolest [ __ ] right exactly so like
so we did that and then you know you
ship those off and I thought it would
just be like kind of a cool page and
like the chapter of that stage of my
life like I don't really have any idea
what would happen and then they called
me like 30 days later and they're like
hey we're kind of building this thing
out would you be interested in being one
of the on-camera people and I was like
that all right right yeah exactly so I
quit my job sold all my [ __ ] got rid of
my apartment in Chicago moved to New
York 30 days later and yeah that was
like four years ago and to now four
years yeah yeah well I want to get into
the rise of the great Sean Evans and
complex and the creation of hot ones
after we get back from this break thank
you to Dollar Shave Club for sponsoring
this episode the H Street podcast listen
it's this simple if you have hair
anywhere on your body okay let's hold it
up together
can you see that if you have hair
anywhere on your body you are messing up
by not using this hefty meaty razor they
collides and destroys any hair on your
body it's the best okay they do
everything to keep you looking and
feeling and smelling your very dang best
they've got shampoo
they've got body wash they've got
toothbrushes and of course the best
razor I've ever used I get an amazing
high-quality shave every morning from
Dollar Shave club's executive razor I
mentioned this previously I have a beard
I don't know if you can call this
stubble a beard it's more like a [ __ ]
like I fell in some dirt and didn't wash
my face some people have beards
but here's what I use it for I use it
right here because it's the only razor
I've ever used it doesn't
give me pimples and make me want to jump
every time I shave my neck you ever get
those things it ruins your whole day
another thing I use it for is the on my
neck I clean up the back of my neck I
feel like an adult it's crazy I don't
have like pubes for growing out this
back of my neck like I did my whole life
it's like disgusting and then you're
like oh that's it's just as easy as that
and you need a great razor to take on
the job of destroying those neck pubes
and they're up for the task I guarantee
it but the true hero of any morning is
dr. Carver's shave butter
you know why Ella because it's bad
because it's butter that's what I was
hoping you'd say oh wait that's the
shame there's guys why eula because it's
about it's about it so this shave butter
is actually incredible it's not foam
it's not cream it's none of this BS it's
butter it's like soft it's like oh my
god you're like a Thanksgiving turkey
just just about to pop in the oven and
then it just destroys their hair it's an
unbelievable experience you're gonna
feel fresh you're gonna feel beautiful
you're gonna have to get this you guys
another must have experience is the
Dollar Shave Club it delivers it all to
your freakin door so you don't they go
talk to some dweebs at the supermarket
who own the summer job weren't even hit
puberty trying to give you advice about
razor used please whatever talk to the
hand
that means no more trips to the store
wandering the aisles hunting for razor
shampoo toothpaste then having a play at
being a cashier scanning your bagging
your own stuff
oh wow why don't just work why am I just
your employee Ralph's you just pay me to
bag my own [ __ ] this is America no you
get we get [ __ ] our tour doors now we
don't leave the house
that's the American spirit for
mind-blowing experience join Dollar
Shave Club today for just five dollars
with free shipping you'll get six blade
executive razor plus trial sizes of the
shave butter the Bobbsey the body
cleanser the one wipe Charlie Oh got him
throw it out all done fresh then keep
the blades coming for a few bucks a
month more after your trial is over get
yours at Dollar Shave Club home slash h3
that's dollarshaveclub.com
/ h3 guys thank you Dollar Shave Club
sponsoring us please hit him up if you
need a razor and you do because you have
hair on your body
next up is my longtime favorite freakin
thing in the world
quit Cool Whip is in vibrating little
tube that other people also call no as a
toothbrush have you guys ever bought an
electric toothbrush let me just preface
by saying this I was in the market for
electric toothbrush a couple of years
ago before I knew about quit and I'm
looking at all these name brands all
these super fancy it's like 200 bucks
for a good electric toothbrush I was
like what I bought it because I'm a SAP
and I was like I don't even like it that
much because it's like super bulky you
feel like you're like doing road
construction in your mouth that's why I
quit was like okay let's let's address
this $200 no starting at $25 how about a
sleek design that not only vibrates the
perfect amount to clean your teeth but
also tells you when to switch sides it
you turn it on it vibrates every 30
seconds it does pulsating so you know oh
that sides done you freaking Kimmy it's
like having a dentist in your mouth at
all times keeping a higher now you're
keeping taking care of things
there's nothing worse in life than
stinky breath and bad oral hygiene I'm
telling you if you're trying to get if
you're trying to dip your care in some
branch dressing you need to keep your
mouth fresh as possible and quit is the
best a good toothbrush will nearly get
you at 25 bucks this thing is going to
last you it's gonna keep your mouth
clean it's the best product I personally
endorse it I love it I'm not blowing
smoke up your ass if you don't have a
quip you need it I'm dead serious
that was some serious [ __ ] let me put it
this way both most toothbrushes don't
get named one of Time Magazine's best
invention of the year
no but quip did if you want to find out
why get one for yourself here's the deal
quip starts at just 25 bucks if you go
to get quip comm slash h3 right now and
you'll get your first refill pack
absolutely free with a quip electric
toothbrush that's
first refill pack for free the top pops
off you put the top on you forget about
it this is it free at get quick calm /h
3 that is GE t qu IP comm /h Lee there's
something else I wanted to read here
including free shipping worldwide how
the hell is that possible really after
being in the shipping game from our side
I was like how do you ship like a piece
of lint Australia they charge you under
buck well anyway I can't endorse this
proc enough so guys thank you so much to
quip for sponsoring us
welcome back everybody to the h3 podcast
live so you started as a reporter for
complex you covered Ninja Warrior
Training Kim Kardashian book signing FBI
training course etc what is the most
memorable moment you had pre hot wings
days at complex oh man there's so many
crazy things one time I ate like the
rock for a whole day right and that was
insane tell me more about that cuz that
I've seen that video and it is insane so
well he has an insane diet where he eats
like nine pounds of food a day including
like three pounds of cod so just cod
like Chipotle burritos of just cod I
daily I think people II don't understand
the dedication and like insanity even
that it takes to maintain that kind of
body it gave me a lot more respect for
him especially to as you get older and
older and older to like more and more
cod like that yeah you just gotta keep
eating that cod but the craziest thing
is like well if you look at Michael
Phelps's diet like during that Olympic
training he had that same thing where
he's doing like 12,000 calories a day or
whatever yeah but he's mixing in some
french toast he's enjoying the thing
about the ROC's diet is it's nothing but
brown rice and broiled veggies and fish
and then nuts they just bring out the
plates one after one after one after one
and they'd all way as much as like a
Range Rover tire and he'd just be
digging that for kids I'm thinking that
accordion gnarly [ __ ] it has to be
insane so I like going and going and
going and I can't handle that
like I eaten like a bird unless I can
just drain a G pen and like hit a
Mexican restaurant then I can set some
records but like just normal I can't eat
like that so I just be going into fork
and feeling like I'm just killing this
thing for a half hour and I wouldn't
even put a dent in it no it was just
like a drop in the bucket and then the
next meal is always like on the way so
it's not one time I worked at a worked
at a convenience store high in Colorado
that was like a pretty fun weird thing I
actually yeah god I had a question about
that video watched it at the end or
during that video some stoner guy comes
in and there was plants throughout the
video hey you seem like a cool guy you
want to blaze a joint and I was
there's no way this is real so here's
the thing like yeah like during that
there's all these you know like and you
knew that that would happen like I knew
they'd set me up with like a shoplifter
and here's the thing too like when I
smoke I'm not really like a social guy
you know like I'm not like Rihanna I
can't go sit courtside at a basketball
game you know I can't handle the eyes
like I'm like I can barely get through
like a self checkout it's on this yes
like I need to be boom in a room with
just a friend or two like watching
movies with like Sean on deck so I even
told the people like when I was doing it
I'm like there's like a 50/50 chance
like at some point I'm gonna be like
wait I'm like a bunch of hidden cameras
on me like I'm the middle I'm gonna grab
three frozen Snickers and just go back
to the hotel without saying anyone yeah
it was a war Sean going right bro yeah
so I held through it and then yeah you
knew that there'd be plants like I knew
that like they'd send in somebody who
would do something weird and like send
somebody in to shoplift so there was
always like I always had like a antenna
out but also at the same time I thought
too that there'd be like somebody
helping me through the register and [ __ ]
but it was very like alright here's how
the register works like I'll be in the
back like here you go you know some
people come up and beg Oh like they'd
get a sandwich from the deli like order
another quote like they actually did
like I really let me fly free but that
guy to when he was going up to me and he
was just hanging out I was like this has
to be a plant like just but it wasn't
that was real dan was going are you a
stranger at a cashier first I mean he
was like hey you seem cool you want to
blaze here too like at the same time
like I wasn't being that polite - yeah
well I wasn't being that chill with him
I was kind of like already had like a
bunch of plates spinning that I was
trying to keep up and I was like well
this guy's being annoying and in my head
I'm like well I bet this is just like
the stereotypical stoner guy that they
sent in here to like [ __ ] with me I was
actually getting like semi annoyed with
them so I was being like dismissive and
not really [ __ ] with him like at all
and he's just hanging out and then at
some point like cuz I'd have like a
thing in my ear or whatever so I could
like talk to whoever is like in the van
or downstairs or whatever and at one
point I'd turn around I'm like is this
like your guy somebody doesn't call him
off like this has ended this gag isn't
working
came out of my face like let's get on to
the next thing and I was like is this a
guy like we do not know in some like
right well I'm gonna go meet him out
back by the dumpsters and just so Shawn
went back with the cameras into like the
only thing that disappoints me about
that video is like one time I got this
19 minute cut of it and I was like this
shit's funny as [ __ ] and then they cut
it down to like some like little yeah 4
minute video hoping for more panic
attacks yeah exactly like the 90 minute
videos like chopped it down into this
like very just snackable little video
that was like cute I guess but like the
19 minute I was like it was like I was
like this is like real art I was uh how
did you become the hot ones guy how was
the show conceived are you the creator
of the show so Chris Schoenberger who
runs first we feast
me and him we were always like just cut
like just friendly in the hall and just
had a good rapport and then one day he
came up to me and he's like hey I have
this idea for a show where we interview
celebrities but eat violently hot
chicken wing mm-hmm and the way that
that hit my ear I was like that's the
funniest so you know we get into a room
we're like laying all the things laying
everything out we call in Tony Yayo from
g-unit to help shoot the pilot and so
he's helping us workshop out the beats
too and then what you see now like at
back then I think it's maybe like the
first episode is maybe like seven wings
we didn't really have any idea of what
it was or what it would be we kind of
thought it would be this funny show we
always had dreams of it being this sort
of Internet sideshow but never like this
aspiration right powerful serious yeah
great exactly so what you see now after
110 episodes is just shall we
Congrats yeah when you say that out loud
I just yeah it's nuts it's nuts every
Thursday for like two years um was it a
hard sell to the bosses at complex the
concept well at the time it was so wild
wild west I mean I could like go into
some things that you know maybe could
have been handled better at higher
levels but like they kind of were out of
our way like they were kind of like if
you guys are gonna do this thing in this
weird room they were so focused on other
projects that they
really believed in and us we were just
like some like whatever
yeah like whatever kind of like doing
this in the dark and then you know I
actually think is you know in a lot of
ways what helps to show become what it
is is that there were so few hands off
chefs in the kitchen it was just me and
Chris and we could make this thing work
on our terms and you know people would
come in with that Veidt like you know
people be like it should be six minutes
I got it out and we would just be like
just thank you thank you thank you okay
cool like all these people like maybe
there should be peppers do we have to do
10 I think you know like all these
people okay cool well can you just like
go over here and it's like me and Chris
could just still like to this point it
could just be us and then because of
that I think it's given us a little bit
of elbow room because we like really
stuck to what we wanted to do and then
now it's to a point where like nobody
really they can't say yeah they can't
really cross any lines because we're
just like this is exactly exactly
it almost remind me of like how Seinfeld
came to be anyway but I think that
that's with a lot of these goats that
float you know what I mean like if you
have too many people who have ego not
much know how like have a title and not
much know how getting into the way of
these sorts of things that's what sinks
those you know but it's just me and
Chris kind of being naive picking it up
as we learning really paying attention
to our audience being motivated by like
the growth because it wasn't always a
big hit show as you guys know like how
long did it take to get to from 0 to
10,000 subscribers you know so it's like
you really have to believe in what
you're doing because there is no
immediate payoff and I think brands big
media companies they don't let ideas
evolve you know like they don't really
let things grow so I think that the fact
that we were so misunderstood and
underrated and put into of one hour do
you guys that's what empowered us for
sure I hope someone I hope someone at a
media company is listening they should I
guarantee they're not but they should
they should and if you have a budget
yeah really planning for it you know
it's just one of those things that just
happen I think that you know you can you
can make some chess moves along the way
to help you succeed and you can't make
people [ __ ] with you you just gotta get
on it and you
you have a good idea it doesn't
necessarily mean that the planes gonna
take off I'm sure it wasn't your guys
first attempt and it's like you have to
keep hitting and hitting and hitting and
hitting and then when you find some of
the hits you ride it exactly exactly
what I I saw you say somewhere that the
whole concept behind the show was that
you guys wanted to make a celebrity
interview show that didn't suck right
and I know a way to disarm them in a way
too right and the solution to that which
was hot ones was so beautiful and
elegant I'm wondering if there was any
other early versions of the show before
the spicy hot wings idea came in do you
guys were considering no it's just like
Chris just saying that line let's
interview celebrities but make them eat
violently hot chicken I'll never know
really it was crucial like you just said
spicy wings a pilot he was like
violently hot wings like it was like
revolutionary all good ideas can be
expressed with that much clarity exactly
into I think that all great ideas or
inventions or whatever you're solving
for a problem that maybe people didn't
even know they had so you know you have
the celebrity interview format which is
such a tired format and so we're like
well how do we make these interviews not
boring you have so many celebrities
they'll sit down there in a PR driven
flight pattern right how do we disrupt
that and our answer for that was violent
violently hot bias so the show wasn't an
instant hit it sounds like it wasn't no
I mean it took a while I think um here's
here's but here's what it was so it
would go out and maybe we'd get like
8,000 views or like 25,000 really sore
whatever like when I'd wake up the next
day like that's what it would say and I
was always like feel like this should
gain more trust better right it's better
than but here's what motivated me is
that everybody who watched it seemed to
love it you know the comments were like
this is [ __ ] amazing like this is
gonna blow up this is gonna be huge you
know what I mean it had such a cult
thing from the beginning so I was like
well if we can just get more people in
the tent you know what I mean like
that's the whole thing so we talked
about the tent pole episodes all the
time there is
a video that you saw with me and chili
Klaus eating it's one of his favorite
videos are both oh man that was one of
the early that's very early episodes
okay and that was our first sort of like
I got millions and millions of viewers
like the number one thing on Reddit I do
collect anything from that video when he
shot it because you adored a lot for
that promise of very little and that it
was yeah that's a good way to put it but
I did just believe in it you know I just
did me and Crispian too cuz it was like
you know it was also to the chip on her
shoulder that was created by being
pushed to the side for like other things
we're like alright you know so we just
did this thing like on our own for so
long and that when that blew up you're
like whoa this is crazy
and then the key and peele one was like
a really great level up situation where
that was a huge picked up by every
website or everything and then - it
helped validate the show in that we
could now pitch people's because that
was like so hard early on those are a
huge huge talent exactly so they're like
oh well this legitimizes the show plus
it took off in such a crazy way that now
it's you know it helped get the train on
the tracks for sure like those two
things those two videos were especially
early on I was gonna ask did you have
trouble booking guests at first because
kind of a hard sell isn't it yeah
because in you know it's even to this
day because on paper it does sound so
insane you know like like you said
earlier people that know the show you're
like you're in because you understand
that it's not just this gimmick you know
that disruptive element in the interview
but it's an interview show first you
know but if you don't know it and you're
like in you're a celeb your movie star
and then you know YouTube is already in
some or circles kind of a nose up
situation and if you have two offers
like hey Jimmy Kimmel wants to interview
you right versus some guy won't seat hot
wings with you on YouTube exactly but
you know Ian - cuz you could like you
could go to Sirius and hit a bunch of
radio shows on an afternoon like yeah we
require an hour and if time was there's
that caveat of the ten scorching hot
chicken wing so it was a very hard sell
early on we were kind of like almost
sure
again people are asking favors there are
some and this is true like some guests
early on that actually like that pitch
like when they saw that pitch they're
like hey God [ __ ] funny you know some
people it does like connect on the
wavelength but it did take a lot more
persuading and a lot more seven types of
smoke early on to give up on that seat
than it does now but that doesn't take
away from the fact that it actually it
still is a challenge yeah it's funny I
think an appearance on your show would
do more to to promote something than
like all the other stuff combined like
it's soap it's that powerful you I know
that and you know that yeah you know but
it takes some it's tough to know yet
right it's not YouTube it's the whole
everything on YouTube and new media is
just like whatever but like the power
behind it right and then too is it's
like the fans will like shout out like
who they want they will times like the
rock is somebody who fans obviously or
to see on the show Gordon Gordon bill
burr Philly D until we got him the word
Hilbert right exactly but to bill you
know like he gets the pitch and we've
hit him and one time I did the show AOL
billed and he was like behind me I
figured out like what kind of cigars he
likes cigar store and I bought these
expensive cigars and I like left him in
the green room with like a note you know
like I've done you know a lot you know I
know you know Bert like Bert you know
knows Bill and those guys Joe Rogan's
know it's like a guy that wants the show
so bad maybe shoot him shoot him tax can
you help me out blah blah blah
so it's like you always do that but it
might not click with them like if they
haven't seen a never maybe they just are
really don't [ __ ] with spicy food I
actually would love the show I do feel
like you bill I do but yes the there is
something that has to get you to click
over like Eric Andre show that was my
favorite show I never even heard about
it until like the third or fourth season
you know what I mean like there does
have to be something that clicked right
and then other than that yeah and then
beyond that to is it's like these people
are busy as [ __ ] yes and nobody
necessarily wants to do press you know
like if you have really like you and I
are buddies like we'd text like how long
was it like how long did take even for
this to work out you know what I don't
even when I'm in LA or whatever you know
it's just tough and I'm not that [ __ ]
busy that's very true
you mentioned in your aim
may that at first you were more or less
conning people into doing the show what
did you mean by that well I'll take like
there's a couple things that come to
mind where it would be in the DJ Khaled
episode right he's doing sneaker
shopping and he has you know like
buddies at complex who we kind of like
made them pass along as a favor and he's
kind of agreeing but doesn't really
understand what is gorgeou not chicken
wings you know that's what's wrong yeah
so he was like totally taken by surprise
I remember Tinashe she was doing a cover
shoot for the magazine and we're like
you know while you're doing this
six-hour cover shoot like slitted set up
our black curtain and did this show and
they're like oh is this some sort of
like ancillary added value video or like
yeah stuck in that seat you can see the
show like you're stuck you're crouched
you did everything you could think and
there's and the spirit of a really the
climb on YouTube I think everyone's
you've really been through the the
gauntlet no I know and it's learned I've
learned a lot since then and it has been
just such a crazy thing I think that
that's probably what people don't
understand is that yeah this is like
seven people who are setting their hair
on fire every week and then putting it
out in a garbage can full of ice cubes
just to make sure that the next episode
can happen you know and there's a lot
that happens with that Plinko ball when
it goes down before that that you know
before that can secure itself so it's
been crazy it's been nuts it's gotten a
lot easier and I'm very grateful for
that but you know it's still uh it's
still a grind yeah I mean well with more
views and more subscribers and higher
profile guests the pressure is on it
doesn't I mean it doesn't go away it
doesn't go away plus - because then once
you do like a hunt you know like you're
like what you know like who's out blah
blah blah you know like somebody's in a
pressed or somebody can do this somebody
can do that but yeah it's it's it's not
it's not has anyone ever gotten sick
during the show oh yeah
like who are the worst who has taken it
the worst in here so you know when you
say that the impulse is to go to people
who tapped out you know like
Jim Gaffigan or Rob Corddry or Ricky
Gervais and be like those are the guys
that but actually I think that in most
cases those were just guests being
sensible and being like this is getting
crazy like I want out right when I
really think about who had the hardest
time Martin garrix really suffered for
the art you know like hey it's the
people who are dying and then they just
keep going to the net wing and to the
next wing Julio he was passed out in our
green room for like an hour out of that
yeah he was just there and then like
it's all glass the green room that he
had at the time and we were in an office
space although they're doing people it's
not very private at all it's Coolio
passed out Martin garrix it was so funny
because he was just killing milk of the
whole time and while it was happening I
was like that's gonna be a problem cuz
he can't like put away a gallon of milk
without puking just right physically
yeah yeah so you know he has a team with
like all these like vloggers like you
know following him around and stuff and
I always think about these you know he's
a little he's a kid he's the sweetest
guy ever we love him we talk about him
all the time and you know he had this
thing where like at the end he's like
where's the bathroom like oh like over
there and to the left and like the
vloggers kind of like following around
like as you shouldn't he was like go
away like back in your home and then I'd
hear like all these stories from people
that were working in the office we've
since moved but like in the office at
the time a big dude I was just in the
stall I hear somebody dry heaving in the
sink like and is like and then I walk
out and it's just riffraff and a peach
talk just dry heaving in the sink so
it's like we've had so many stories
countless stories like it's all like
blurred into one what if what are the
two do you ever feel bad like or is it
just but you do but then you're like
it's good TV you know like there it is
part of both really good ways and they
signed up so there is a part of me it's
not that bad they're not they're not
actually but it is great they are you
can you hear about beautiful moment
exactly did Bobby Lee
Bobby Willie's actually our next guest
oh really did he shoot his band so
here's all super can't say you weren't
in Italy
right because I didn't we didn't resume
La Paz Underpants or anything but here's
it all same sitting on this side of the
table relative to Bobby Lee he like got
up in it like had a sound that was
sloshed like just like the surgery like
a cooler with the low water on the
bottom yeah it was like or it was like a
melon being dropped it didn't really
happen definitely have these sound that
was like anything other than what it
what it seemed to be you know so like
wow that was happening I was like did
something just happen because I didn't
know how else but you know I think that
he kind of even was you know he's such a
pretty such an artist he's a performer
that I think like you know he probably
could have held it but he brought was
just like whatever let him embrace Peyer
to have that little level giving a [ __ ]
God willing I'm so glad you're here will
you please grace us with [ __ ] your
pants I'll do is do I feel like I could
[ __ ] my pants at any time I'm a boy
scrunch - all right I'm gonna drop I'm
about to drop this cantaloupe dude
I caught controversial our last guest
was I thought you were buying [ __ ] Bob
Saget was here last week my boy yeah it
was like shredder was rubbing on his
feet and right after we turned off the
cameras he's like dude I thought you
were playing footsie with me the whole
time and it was freaking me out I didn't
want to say anything but I was really
weirded out it was just shredder I was
like I feel bad I was Bob great he's not
no it was great that's great it was
awesome it was it was a beautiful moment
sit across from the SAG yeah yeah
controversal E am I saying that I think
that's what I think I'm saying that
right which guests have taken it the
best you can say what we've had Ethan
you're pretty good you know it's hard to
tell because there's people that like
just let it fly and then sometimes you
have somebody who the way they'll handle
something in that moment is they will
like just get quiet and
focus and whatever so sometimes it's
hard to tell but when I'm looking back
Dax Shepard he had enough in him to just
pour hot sauce I'm definitely know what
in the next wing one of my regrets was
that I didn't go harder with the sauce
really yeah because we were just taking
them has that been tough that's that one
here well no because I feel like I took
a bite and I threw it out right but I I
have to acknowledge that eating a whole
wing which a lot of people do at the end
versus taking a bite is a world of
difference it is in it isn't because
it's like everybody's kind of different
so maybe you know a little nibble for
somebody who doesn't you know can't mess
with spice at all is an unbearable thing
for them to go through and then on top
of that you know is lights camera action
with all these lights on you know all
these cameras on them and it's like it
is an uncomfortable thing so I
understand when people are like alright
I'm gonna do this because I need to get
through this but I'm not committing and
such a crazy way to like clearing this
whole wing plus ten wings is kind of a
lot of food they didn't want you know
and then sometimes you know because
whatever sometimes we'll have a shoot at
like 9:00 or 10:00 in the morning so you
ever have to just go out wait for
someone sometimes like a fried chicken
those wings were in temp room temp yeah
well that's better than ice cold but
they weren't icicle but they were safe
they were like they were not good well
you know what we've we've really stepped
it up chilling on our tripod and I'm
like you have a lot of very expensive
equipment and a lot of wires yeah yeah
I've heard you guys have stepped up the
wing we have delivery we have mechanisms
and yeah we have like a whole we have a
whole thing now we never really thought
about the wings and all cuz it says
really matter though it right and to
because it is you know I think that in a
lot of ways the way we've been able to
punch out of our weight class with gas
is because we do have this stripped-down
budget set that we can pop up whenever
wherever you know like we can do it in
an LA Senor New York or you know shoot
Russell Brand and Ricky Gervais some
London or whatever so I think that it's
even with the hell I lost my train of
thought are we talking about the wings
oh yeah or maybe we can just pop
like a junket or in a hotel room like
Charlize Theron we just booked a suite
at the Four Seasons so you'll be like
okay well like Charlize is coming at
that's so cool I would never even expect
that you don't want all shot in the same
studio space right exactly but that's
it's like that's really what's helped
you need some wings in song right and
with that also too that's what makes it
tough on temperature because like
alright Charlize is gonna be here at
2:00 p.m. so yeah
alright cool and you got everything set
and then it's like 205 207 208 208
they're getting a little bit softer
she's gotta come in she's got to get
miked
she's got to sit down got it light it
got its lady you know and like that time
is just ticking and then by the time
they bite in they're like this is kind
of cold
you know the interview is an hour long
an hour and 10 minutes long so it's like
whatever by the time you get to the 6th
like maybe it's like cold then but we've
done a lot to make sure that it's like
served up that's good it's it comes with
the experience 110 episodes yeah I will
say though what he said
cuz I the first like six I ate entirely
and then I was like man I actually don't
want to eat another full wing right you
get full it's full it's filling yeah I
wish I would have waited saw the tent
that too it kind of builds you up
alright guys we are gonna roll to a
quick break there's only one spot so
please don't go anywhere
it's quick it's dirty also it's a viagra
we're selling viagra so you're not gonna
miss it trust me it's not exactly cut it
off hurry talk about a great sponsor
okay hims coming up next I love these
guys because basically they're making
the h3 army multiply let me tell you I
sexual performance issues more common
than you think
over 25% of new erectile dysfunction
cases are guides under 40 okay guys
under 40 are struggling to maintain an
erection and that's just not right it's
not right
it shouldn't be like that you should be
having a raging boner until the day you
[ __ ] die and they should they should
plant ubique firs in the ground with
their raging [ __ ] that's the way it
should be and and that's what they're
about making sure happens why do guys
turn to weird solutions or nothing when
they can turn to
medicine and science for hems comm a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual and wellness for men thanks to
science Edie can be optional him
connects you with real doctors and
medical grade solutions to treat Edie
well known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescriptions can help you
combat Edie no this is not a scheme this
is an actual drug that because of the
generic copyright on this drug it's
viagra its fogger they keep scrubbing
around they're like oh it's a started
with V it's FRA Agra they're selling
about generic equivalent of viagra okay
it's gonna get your dude your what is it
the kendrick lamar said I hope my dick
gets as big as the Eiffel Tower so I can
[ __ ] for 72 hours there's no waiting
rooms there's no awkward doctor visits
there's no line save hours by going to
for hems calm it's so easy answer a few
quick questions and chat with a doctor
for a confidential review products are
shipped directly to your door
severe Edie isn't just an issue for rich
old guys and bathtubs specific it
affects men in the 30s and 40s bring
your best means performing being your
best means perform your best no one
person doctor visit not anymore its
erectile without this function hard made
easy say hello to your little friend
try hymns for month today for just $5
will get you started with just five
bucks while supplies last
see website for full details this will
cost you a hundred bucks if you went
through a doctor pharmacy here's the
deal go to four hams calm slash h3 Edie
yes h3 Edie and that's not an accusation
against me in any way
it's just the URL so that's four hams fo
are hims calm / h3 ed4 hymns calm / HD
guys if you are in the market for a
blade a razor or a big-ass hard flippin
carrot to dip in that ranch dressing
please consider supporting our sponsors
thank you for watching let's get back
and do it there any anything that's true
that's true for sure hopefully they'll
come a day when [ __ ] people understand
that are we alive
we're waiting for you laughter right
there yeah it's okay I can start the
thing is we have a youtube cut so this
kind of banter will just cut out [ __ ] it
just keep it at man
or keep it in but we're waiting for ela
respect there's no show without elo we
meet me and Sean were just talking
off-camera about how like people from
traditional media don't understand how
good doing shows like pastry podcast
would be to come promote something or
hot ones compared to whatever other
stuff they're doing right because always
I've thought that forever because we
have big audiences and then highly
targeted eyeballs and then it's in a
sort of a crowdsource way like you know
who people want to see on the h3 pod
right and same so it's right all right
like if you do this like for the people
like that's actually what they want it
looked hard to get that to click in
people's brains especially now but I do
feel and you do too and we've benefited
from it that the scales are tipping I
hope so it just takes like a savvy
publicist or a savvy superstar to unwrap
in yeah there's some good savvy
publicist out there who are starting to
understand that yeah like there's
something is something more about like
you're engaged with your fan your
audience in a way that doesn't even
exist
in traditional media exactly when you're
here with somebody they're getting an
experience they're really connected that
that you can't get exactly I think plus
this is realer yeah we're just talking
about how we're just Tooting our own
horn over here we're just talking about
how like well the people watch we're
just talking about people who do shows
on traditional media don't get as much
yeah you know he menials agreed okay
where were we should I cut in Dan or
should we just include this I say I vote
we included I think yeah it was
interesting let's let's include it yeah
we have the where the flip was I so dj
khaled as we mentioned previously a
mutual friend he made it
yeah mutual friend man god bless him he
made it through three wings I guess this
really isn't that demystifying after
hearing your backstory right he didn't
know what he was getting himself into
had no idea and it all took him by
surprise it was really uh he was
blindside did you I mean did you not
lose like a little respect for the guy
like what is number three like deal but
then to it is like historic you know it
is the lowest score of all time by far
in the read I'm almost be impossible oh
yeah and it's impossible it's a sort of
hair but there is part of me that's
always waited and maybe in a sick
twisted way wanted somebody to tap out
early how they're it's like you
willingly if you willingly come on the
show and tap out at one but like its
it's pathetic unpopular and the people
you would live forever but then I'm like
just an anarchy level its rival and airy
but it's kind of like really perfect
it's DJ Colin taking that spot forever
and do like in the same way that we were
talking about audiences like there's so
many people who watch hot ones or have
watched since or the lore behind the DJ
Khaled episode who don't really know dj
khaled the performer right so like they
know him as the guy who tapped out have
you spoken to him since that does he
embrace the the legacy he has on your
show well it's hard to tell I think that
if you hooked him up to a functional MRI
or like a yeah cool guy but like that
thing would just be gone like that and
one time I did see him in the office you
know he was just like walking around
yeah and I was like oh [ __ ] like I'm
gonna give him a bottle of last day have
you know like I'll just run up on him
and he's like he's like what do you what
are you making fun of me yeah right he
had like a team of like twelve people
like the whole thing like they're
walking out in the failings formation or
why are you chewing on our table so I
hold on our dog is eating the table
sorry good and then when he when he
turned the corner I like timed it up
perfectly so I just see him and he
couldn't avoid it I was like hey bro
here this is for you and then he like
looked and then he like got it and then
I was
just I was gone and no words exchanged
yeah I just want to do a little I think
we share just I think he hates us yeah I
think you I mean yeah yeah it's a total
position we kind of got it we kind of
got him a little bit when we met him in
yeah I mean and we and I got him a
little bit you got you definitely got
him he's well I think you know like
there's certain that was one of your
first big guess right I mean count know
he was like and he was real popular at
the time too but no you know I think
that we we caught him like you know his
first ever snapchat and that's like
really what took him you know he was oh
he's always a big you know not to
disrespect DJ Cal because I think that
there's like a lot of people think he
just yells on the microphone he's
actually not exactly legendary DJ I
agree and does deserve more credit than
you know most people are very from a
surface level sure he is that you know
he has played some from the mud he did
come from the money he has this he has
this spot and he does you know he does
deserve and can you grab shredder it is
like but at the same time growing the
show he usually just lives here but now
he thinks it's a game I love you sorry
hell out of here but when he sort of
exploded in sort of an apple commercial
soccer moms everywhere in knowing him
way was with the snapchat sort of these
are the keys to laughs this is the path
that was one way you know he rode that
there's Fame hard harder than he should
have honest check but I don't know
though who's laughing now
Zulu we really caught him at that moment
where you know he was he was exploding
on the internet like the first ever
snapchat he actually did it on the set I
don't know if is the first one but like
when he downloaded and learned what
snapchat was was on the set of hot ones
Wow no yeah so
that whole thing happening with snapchat
like that's what kind of like took his
thing and made it explode I remember
like you know he was always saying like
they them they don't want you to that
was in this music field like the Bahamas
one yeah so he's been saying that
forever and I asked him that question
who are the show I'm like worried they
and he's like losers bombs fuckboys
pieces of [ __ ] no and then I see him on
Ellen like eight months later and Ellen
is like who are they right and then he's
like you know it's that person at work
that's always dogging you like he had a
totally like ironed friendly answer to
that question now he's challenged like
patting herself on the back like she's
the first person that asked like who are
they - DJ Khaled gets this moment but I
remember thinking that that was funny
seeing that Archon Khaled like going
from the DJ Khaled from before there's
like a BC you know like there's like a
line and then to see that before hot
ones in that total mainstream crossover
and then like The Ellen Show and the way
that he answers the who are they
question well the best dj khaled moment
for me yeah yeah as always have to be
you have a favorite dj khaled moment
mine is and he got lost on the jet skis
and it was like on snapchat saying to
call yeah he's like whatever Katherine
hard with him to know where the words
but it was amazing watching that happen
Lionel unsnapped yeah I just feel like
that I feel like there was a rawness to
the internet back then that's gone and
it wasn't that long ago - right yeah but
that was during like when pranks in the
hood was happening and like you know
spider-man like pedis the aisles were
running wild wild west for running
YouTube and Khalid was lost at sea and
we just had like all this content was
like oh my god a lot of fodder for the
the reaction video what happened need
come back the problem is that YouTube
doesn't allow that [ __ ] anymore
mmm but all the stuff we would we were
talking about then YouTube it's like
doesn't even allow it on the platform
now and now what's happening is they're
removing our videos our old ones and our
new ones because we're talking about it
oh really
but people don't to hear me [ __ ] about
YouTube yeah that is what's happening
like now we can't even make fun of [ __ ]
because they don't just they don't
differentiate between criticism and the
actual source it's just like it was in
your video and we're gonna do monetize
it or remove it so yeah they're just
scrubbing the whole history yes
interesting what the incredible success
that you guys had and it seems like
nobody cared about your show in the
beginning real underdog story clearly
now upper management and the people are
running the show know about you guys
mm-hmm how did they react to the success
of your show and has it came up where
they were like oh [ __ ] like what was
going on there yeah I mean I think that
it's gotten so loud that you can't
really ignore it anymore so you know
it's it's definitely a crown jewel of
the whole operation I would say well I
appreciate you saying that it is it's
not objective I mean it is objective
yeah I think you know it's gotten so
loud and then that's you know made
things definitely easier on me and Chris
so you know you look into the future and
hope that that can get ironed out even
more so I'm definitely optimistic about
that for sure
hmm I want to ask you something my cell
on the Internet has how is taco gate
affected your career oh man and has the
backlash finally gone down well now I
think now it's it's it's it's it's born
again if you guys can see Shawn taking a
bite out of the top of the damn taco
twice as if oh nothing is as if nothing
so I'll defend this definitely I'll
defend this here's I defended on a
couple grounds and I didn't actually you
know like I did Philly D yesterday and
he brought up taco gate really now it's
it's like a whole new of life with taco
game here's what I think happens like to
me I've always eaten a taco that way and
it makes sense to me on a couple levels
like I like that meat tube at the end
and I don't really care about the
lettuce and the cheese or whatever is
flowing oh I'm just trying to get to
them would you ever make trying to get
like a task out of the way plus it's a
way cleaner way to eat a taco like you
don't end up with everything all over
this well the problem well it is cleaner
but you're also not really but who are
you to tell me well why don't you just
make a ground beef taco why [ __ ] around
with anything at all well listen why you
should why not just wine is when buying
a taco why not just remove the top part
and have a little meat to listen you
could do you break the shell it breaks a
little bit now you're like now you have
like this fracture look clearly at the
end you have to eat it properly you
can't eat it from the top all the way
through I'll go conk Goong Goong Goong
take that thing down and then it's just
taken the to the other pause the tube
down from the other side you know I I
will defend this oh thank you let's try
eating a talk of it because you're a
mouthful I'll try it
there's too much mutts you clean it up
it's not so much they put it in there
it's cleaner no however you eat a taco
if you were eating pizza and you just
turned that thing around and ate it
crust first I would just be like well
that's just how you you would you be
like this guy's a [ __ ] lunatic I'm
never hanging out with this is something
that I that we've talked about
previously and it's something that
interests me I feel like on the internet
when you get to a certain size or not
just the internet but anywhere in life
to a point where people are looking up
at you that you get haters but you I
feel like you're a guy that there's
nothing to hate about cuz you're just a
dude making a show that everybody loves
so my question do you have haters yeah I
mean I think that as its as it's gotten
more popular like weirder things happen
and like the TWiT you know my mentions
do get weird and like it isn't as fun
anymore you know when I
first starts and you're putting these
things out everybody is kind of rallying
to it because they're fans of it and
they want it and you're fun to root for
when you don't have [ __ ] yeah you know
like people root for you but then I do
think that like it's gotten to a point
where I used to like going into the
message boards and reading it or like
going into the comments and now I don't
like I don't look because you never know
when you're just gonna get smacked
upside the head with something that just
makes like you know whatever like I'm
human so it's like but that's my fault
for like going into that and you know
trying to figure that all all out I do
think that there is a value to having
that real life focus group at all times
and you guys do that in the way that
you're connected to the subreddit in the
way that you're connected to the fans
and there is you know I always want that
connection
but I'm not going elbow deep into the
comments anymore like you know it's just
like even the things that and this is
like on me too but like even things that
are like stupid drive me insane like
it's not even somebody being hateful or
like crazy to me that bothers me like
you kind of can't live on the internet
and have that bother you otherwise
you'll be out of there in two seconds
but it's like sometimes I'll get a DM
that's like you know like whatever like
that's like hey my friend ouch having a
bachelor party would you fly out
tomorrow and do a live hot ones with us
like it was so cool like that you know
and always like well I appreciate that
but then I'm always like kind of
thinking like well like dude am I do
they expect me to like book a flight and
then like go there and then like what's
the situation cuz they didn't really
give me a ton of details like am i
hanging out at like the house that they
rented like am I out of pocket on a
hotel and then I'll start thinking about
these things like wait as you imagine
and then I got back yeah I'll just be
like at the gym and I can't like shake
these like sort of like weird requests
and like weird things and just like from
and I'm always like thinking about it so
then even that so like it's just so much
messaging and like so many things going
on and then it is a minefield where you
could just get to somebody that's like I
[ __ ] hate you I hope you die you know
like that and then you're just like it's
just a little too
crazy you know for me so now that you're
like internet-famous
what is that the thing that's affected
you the most is there are other things
that have come up that you didn't expect
or how's your life changed basically
yeah I mean yeah it's cool like people I
mean that's it's good because in real
life it's a totally different experience
than whoever is barking at you online
like yeah in real life people are like
super cool great yeah and then you know
like companies like though like oh my
god you know Shawn and that to me is
like greatest the [ __ ] best yeah the
best you'll see people like light up or
like double-team a big that's somebody
you know somebody who's watched a bunch
of hot ones and then they think they
[ __ ] with the show and then they like
see and then like if they ask about the
show or they have a question like that
to me is like the coolest thing so it is
such a positive experience in real life
and then like yeah like maybe the door
guy does recognize you at the club like
maybe you know like you are at a
restaurant like earlier today I was
having brunch and they're like oh this
is like from the kitchen from Roy Troy
like oh my god this is so nice like this
salmon toes you know like these like
these whole like these things that are
happen that are just amazing like even
tonight I want to go see like Chris
D'Elia and Coco at the Comedy Store and
so like I'm like I'm like you know like
in the DMS with Chris like hey can you
hook something up you know like all
those things like are amazing you know
like that is like even if you know the
the paycheck ain't there like even if
like the other things aren't there maybe
you're feeling like [ __ ] or like
whatever like that is all cool because
you're making people happy with a show
and then they want to pay that back like
you want to show that they're
appreciative but like doing some sort of
a favor for you or like helping them out
or like making you laugh or like making
you smile or making you feel good the
way that you make them feel good so I'd
like treasure that so much yeah that is
the best I think that true genuine fans
on the streets are always it so it's so
nice that it's hard to understand that
it's real and like really take it in
because it's like it's amazing it's too
much exactly and then so that to like
kind of cancels out so then you're like
well if I can just focus on the video
and the interview and just making the
next one and kind of live in the real
world a little
more than like diving into Internet and
the chatter and like all that then it's
probably just a healthier way to live
your life I'm a mental health level on
every level and so I've been more and
more inching towards that sort of thing
but I don't want to lose that connection
like I care about like what fans are
saying in the comments I care about like
what people in like a discussion thread
or whatever like thinking about the show
and I don't want to like lose that
connection at all so I guess I would say
I'm peripherally aware yeah I touch it
but I'm not like doing a cannonball into
that pool I would say the same thing
yeah like I feel like we generally
always know what people think yeah and
when you go in and try to like get it
its way it's just depressing right a lot
of times but it's like you know you get
the idea right you don't need somebody
to like [ __ ] in your face I understand
what you think and usually I agree yeah
like you know it's not everyone's a
hater either you know there's construct
yeah so and I think that like once you
start thinking that way that's not a
good thing either so you know it's may
be good to get knocked down a peg in the
fact that everyone can tell you what
they think all the time you know it's
maybe somewhat helpful balance that yeah
it kind of keeps you yeah keeps down the
track I want to say I hold your
interview skills to be among the
greatest I'm definitely not on load that
you are definitely known for your
incredible interviews thank you so my
question to you is what is your research
process like yeah so it's it is what it
looks like it's just elbow grease you
know that's the thing about hot ones
that is it is just by design a labor
intensive show and I think that it's
just as important to do it myself you
know
and not that I do it all by myself like
at this point I've got like my little
brother doing dossiers and then
Christian Berger who's my creative
partner and all this what we'll do is
we'll divide and conquer so I'll send
him all the profiles and local paper
stories and magazine articles and
whatever that I'm gonna read and with
the podcast I'm gonna listen to if it's
an artist will listen to their music if
it's an
actress will watch her move you just
drop everything when you have booked the
guest like how much do you commit to
just researching and consuming every
minute that I have so sometimes you know
you don't have that much of a lead time
like maybe you're able to confirm
somebody and shoot it in a matter of
like 48 hours you know what if that's
what I have then whatever then I'm not
gonna drop you drop everything that
possible and you just boom consume
everything well you have to and I think
too as the show's grown you know now
there are like more and more
expectations like it's funny because
like at the beginning when like stuff
was getting 15,000 views you're like
whatever but then like there's part of
you that almost wishes not that I want
to say that like not that I want the
show to fall off but like now I already
know that like millions of people are
gonna see it so I can't embarrass myself
right onerous stage that big so it
actually like ratchet
ratchets that up and then to is you know
the viewer experience is always
different because we have such a wide
array of personalities you know because
it ultimately is just the wings the hot
sauce a black background in a bald guy
so to keep that going at a longevity
level people's expectations only get
higher they see something and then they
need to see something different or see
something better otherwise it's gonna
stay and eventually it's gonna fall off
so I always feel like as the show's
gotten more popular like that process
has actually gotten more intense to a
point that they're all affection
sometimes you have to like manage your
time because as someone who's now
dabbling in interviews doing what we do
here I I'm trying to think of myself
more as like an interviewer and less
like a comedian he's trying to be funny
when I'm sorry here across from somebody
so part of the challenge that I have is
like time management so you find a three
hour podcast you can't listen to the
whole podcast you don't have enough time
right or you know or do you but like
where do you find your nuggets generally
deuce so what I'll do there is like
what's good about the podcast is you can
play that at 2x so like you know what I
mean like really like I might walk to
work like I actually can crank out that
podcast or like whatever like at home
or whatever before I go to bed like I
actually can crank out that podcast or
that book on tape or what-have-you but
just like cranky you're gonna consume it
all in its entirety well here until like
you know you can find these nuggets like
I think what I look at too is like at
this point watching so many interviews
like in research I'll look at body
language as much as I talk about like
what's being discussed because like
sometimes you can see and maybe like an
interview that isn't great that like
that person doing the interview is just
leaving a lot of change on the table
like maybe they'll like ask something
but because they're just thinking about
the next question and because this is
just some sort of formula like they're
not really looking at the guest so like
you can kind of see where like maybe
they're maybe they like perk up a little
bit and then they're like on of the next
questions the person kind like like you
know like you can kind of write you like
maybe they kind of wanted that topic to
be explored a little bit deeper like
I'll just put that topic in that person
together see if I can find like what has
been said about it what's being said
about that thing try to put together
some sort of like hot one style question
around it and that's sort of like you
know just an as much as like finding
these random truffles in the ground like
at the same time you're kind of like
looking at what other interviewers leave
on the table new interesting and I think
to that like I need to know that because
there's so much that can happen on the
spot and so much that you need to improv
in that time and I have to like really
know that person and think about that
person and make that person a box I'm
almost like interviewing that box
because I've done just as much research
and Christian Barry's done just as much
research that we have sort of just this
like armchair psychology mm-hmm
interesting
do you have an interview philosophy like
some kind of guiding principle that that
you find helps you I mean I think it's
just you know you look at what's
interesting to you at some level I think
that's like 30% you think about your
audience to a certain degree and then
you know that I think that like what
people like about hot ones is a
naturally humanizing experience you know
so it's not like taking the celebrity
which by definition is you know these
people living this unattainable
lifestyle you know and then let taking
it down to just a normal level because
like you know if we want to talk about
like in or not famous or you know like
just whatever it's like normal people
I like I like I like when people are
just you know I think that people that
live in that spotlight they like when
people are just being normal to them
they don't like being treated
necessarily like yeah if they're over
here
you know it's like in the process of
like the wings and then contextualizing
a question that's part of the philosophy
I'll circle back on that you can just
take it down to a more human experience
so that's what people like watching it
and feel connected to it I was gonna
touch on something there and just this
well ago I got into that weed chocolate
no it's so amazing to go in these stores
and stuff I'm like I don't I don't like
weed but I'm always shocked with like
the product wait wait here I'm just
that's what I mean amazing not everybody
I know everybody I'm related to blazes
hard everytime wacky new [ __ ] every time
we go to a friend and hang out I end up
consuming it by mistake all right do a
pantry and then yeah like we were at our
friends house and we just grabbed juice
drink from the fridge good juice like
nothing safe yeah no I like I'll have
like a pomegranate juice and it will
just look like pomegranates cuz I know
there's a chance and they still missed
it and every time I think it's happened
actually twice in the past year and
every time it happens we're like we got
a split I gotta go home now it's gonna
be that bad that we need to go home I
need to leave this party just dabbles
I'll take the edge off a little bit but
yeah like if I'm gonna commit then yeah
for sure I need to I can't [ __ ] I can't
[ __ ] with we it just makes me paranoid I
wish I enjoyed it as much as I see
people enjoying it I wish that all the
time for myself I see like there's like
so relaxed apparently but when I take it
it's the opposite of relaxation I think
for me it started off I was like a very
relaxing thing and then like just over
the years it's like yeah when you have
an abortion not going around if you tell
me I'm curious about your process okay
if you were gonna research Sean Evans
like I did where would you start
but how would you start what would that
process look like where would you start
well it just start with like just like a
big like a Google search and just trying
to find out like if the the pillars of
what makes them them like whether it's
like the music whether it's the hobbies
whether it's like whatever find all
those things first and just write all
that down just put that all into a spot
but then what I find too is like into
like social is a good place to go you
know like just start at the bottom of
somebody's Instagram and go all the way
to the top because they're like sharing
these milestones in their life so you
can kind of get a quick download and
then same with the Twitter stuff but
then I think like another thing that you
should look at especially with an
athlete or a big star is their local
paper because those are the people are
gonna be covering them before anybody
else you know I mean so they'll end up
doing those sort of like groundwork
interviews so I think like if you look
at it in a chronological sense that's
helped me a lot it's the link trees
start at day one and then end at where
they are today that's cool try to like
put in all those things like as you see
them pop up and then chess game master
reminds some sort of interview around
what you came up with you so I like a
consistent narrative do you try to do
like a full narrative when you interview
somebody like a story yeah I mean I
think there's that but then you know you
don't want to be locked into a
convention so much you know what I mean
like there's that too so then and then
then you start thinking that way but
then you also don't want to overthink
[ __ ] either yeah you know because like
it is tough it oh there's always like a
balancing act because that's like
sometimes you know you get so into it
you start like working it out I look
like Matt Damon and Good Will Hunting
putting together a question and then you
like well if I ask this person that
they're gonna be like moving breasts
here I don't even know how to answer it
so one of my biggest challenges is like
because it's a live show
dead air is like my worst nightmare if
I'm like like if I'm listening intently
to what you're saying right and then all
the sudden you're done talking because
sometimes people will just like okay and
now I'm done talking right and then if I
don't have the next question like locked
up the worst moment for me is being like
hey come on sec
do you know if you're thinking about
that next question I'm not unless you're
not listening Yeah right so it's tough I
don't know what there's a skill do you
need to sometimes I feel learned I'm
really bad at it well here's that what's
no you're not this is very fun I would
this is a blaster Ethan great thank you
[ __ ] god I wish I was better I wish I
was better at that juggling act but I
think this is like even like I
appreciate the compliment but I think
that too like I think I'm not [ __ ] all
the time I think it's like I think it's
kind of if I was gonna make a comparison
like stand-up comedy or something you
know like your first hundred are gonna
suck but you need that first hundred you
know like you need to just keep stacking
I mean even with the frequency with
which we put out episodes that's like
another thing that I think about to like
I really don't want to take a month off
or two months or three months off and
between seasons like I mean I could use
a [ __ ] vacation but like like because
you know you feel like all right well
then that means that I'm not shooting
jumpers in the gym and that means like
next time it's game time like and get
back you little off exactly so I'm
always just like thinking about how to
hone it's always so hard for us cuz I
have to go visit my family in Israel at
least once a year or twice a year and
that is such a disruption in our you
know schedule really because it's a long
and if you're going that far you might
as well go for not you know a weekend
rather be long and then by the time we
get back it's so hard to get back to
work so I know you mean exactly yeah
it's tough but it's also amazing the
managing to post one every week for so
long that's like I wouldn't I wouldn't
trade the last two years for anything
I'm not sure I could live you know
well I hope that you're not
underappreciated at complex because I
would say and if I'm I'm just saying if
complex was watching this you all Oh
Sean Evans a great debt because you
built a show that they didn't take
seriously into the crown jewel
everybody's looking at complex now
everybody's taking note and you pulling
big fish you're killing it
it's the best showing you don't on and
not even just saying yeah all right
let's see it's nice let's eat some spicy
[ __ ] there's some other questions here
but it's not that interesting let's just
you know and sometimes it's nice to just
close it and then see where the
conversation goes to but I don't know
see I'm always trying to figure out
what's the best way to talk to somebody
and it's just real you know it's real
hard there's no it's no perfect way to
do it you know and then also people like
different things so I would just say
this Ethan this is a [ __ ] amazing
podcast and then but to is it's like
this you can't
YouTube is great and that you can't make
people just ride your wave you have to
build it you know so whatever if you're
able to like put this thing together and
build a channel that has millions and
millions and millions of subscribers
it's because you've committed to a thing
that people like and have been able to
like scale that out and then kept that
at a high level for so long so you need
to stop beating yourself up
[Laughter]
alright so we've got here the pepper X
pepper X last them and we've got here
the Reaper R we got him we've got milk
the crew wanted to get in on this so
they're coming in I love it we've got
Alex we've got Dan we've got who else we
got
oh we're gonna show em ian is coming he
has to stand hit with the meme with Ian
our interns that his face is always
obscured Ian was in the parking lot he
waved down the Yukon yeah well usually
we don't let him in the office
he's just usually sits there and then we
saw him when he'd come there today we're
giving them a special treat lemon being
our presence
all right so how do we are we just gonna
dab it all right sadly Sarah our
switchers unable to join us because
somebody's got to [ __ ] run the show
yeah yeah oh these are good this don't
look good
those don't look good see wings wings
it's complicated logistically Ethan yeah
I'm cam I'm getting appreciation yeah
exactly but I know what 60 episodes into
the podcast if you just keep bringing
these wings out eventually they'll get
it right okay
I'm sorry ting you definitely don't want
unsourced wings have got to be one of
the most on hepatitis sites right so I
mean that's just really not that
appetizing all right so your advice
should we do this so let's just take
well let's go with the app everyone grab
a wing all right all right chip
Dan's a vegetarian so I'm gonna I want
to go pretty hard do you mean play chess
that's all you touch on yeah you know
what here's because like usually the
wings would be sauced with the sauce and
then you'd have an extra dab so maybe we
should just be like a little bit a big
help you're a big boy big boy dad oh my
god I'm gonna shake this up all right
I'm doing a big boy dab this first one
looks like a can you prepare mine yeah
is that so [ __ ] on you that's that's
that's a big boy dab that's a big boy
okay all right you know everyone gets a
big boy dad I don't want anyone to
regret not taking a big boy dad oh yeah
this thing is oh okay make sure shredder
doesn't get a buddy maybe take him out
is this a it's a big boy be a big boy
yeah you're proof yeah he proves Shawn
through the thick boy dab yeah why don't
you uh you can dab go ahead dear I don't
want to I don't want to dab over dab you
and then be like Oh Ethan [ __ ] I'm
suing Ethan yeah just say look into the
camera and say I relieve you guys have
all like all all a liability I will not
sue is that how you guys okay so we're
gonna do two and then let's continue
this conversation so you're gonna do the
X this is cuz then we go G this is the
real one right yeah that's the X and
then that I'm actually
honored to have that cuz it's quite rare
there's not a lot of bottles of that
yeah it's crazy
I was like ninety bucks on eBay yeah I
thought I was why the video about it and
I was like wait man we probably don't
actually have the X and the stash you
sent us thank you I'm do the greater
that's a big boy dad okay everyone's not
you sorry oh that's a big boy dad yeah
no no no regret yeah yeah yeah I'll take
more should I take more you can fear
being generous oh my god all right you
know it's bad when Sean's like that's
too much think this alright I feel like
we're all gonna regret this oh yeah
all right guys let's do this don't eat
into the mic I've made that mistake too
hot great thank you citrusy oh look at
you gone look at a close-up of Sean the
her Oakley her Oaks are gone typically
is it
I can inch it up really good flavor at
yeah I mean alright it was delicious for
the first few seconds it was great I was
making fun of that but the flavor is
real dinner I know nothing and I know
bite cuz I only took half of the dab you
didn't take the old dad it's fine
but you know I was probably a more
sensible decision Wow
oh we did it commit it no matter four
seconds man maybe having a little yeah
breathing heavily are you are you scared
urgent care my mouth is on fire all
right
I'm fine actually it's yeah it was kind
of good I'm going back for seconds there
you go
you know that's cuz that's the thing we
like you want to make it good and then
that's as a very low spice talk it's a
it's a baptism by fire you know how at
this we go
you'll be inching it up like when I was
a howl and raised over there in
Chinatown
this guy's a chef Johnny his own there
he does this amazing Nashville style hot
chicken and it's so hot but it's so good
so I find myself just in this like you
know torturous yeah teen experience but
I kind of can't stop because the chicken
so good I had that problem when I was in
Thailand the food there so spicy but
it's so good yeah he's just yeah you're
torching the tongue it's just the tongue
specifically is very painful on the
right side of my mouth why is it on the
right side some contact I really want to
finish it because everyone did it I feel
like if I do another bite it would make
it looks way worse the second I'm
regretting the first I was like oh that
wasn't so bad I'll go back for seconds
but it really takes a couple minutes to
creep on yeah yeah yeah you know what
though I find it does kind of it's like
you get sort of a head buzz off yeah I
just I mean that's what they say spice
is a beautiful thing because it gives
you the adrenaline rush of being in
danger yeah without actually being
dangerous exactly exactly
whether I'm committed that's why it like
maybe I'm just an addict trying to
trying to chase that your adrenaline -
oh yeah that's why I don't give it up
there's nothing to do with wanting to
perfect it or you know get on top of my
craft like it's all just straight-up
need that hit I think some of it is
stuck in my I feel like um generally I'm
fine but my tongue is on fire yeah
I think it's just wherever a yeah I know
it's the back of my that's why there if
you took like I tried to cheat it I was
like if I swallow it fast maybe that was
because then it hurts later there's no
cheating no shooting but I'll get you
one way or the other
mmm how's everyone yeah yeah it's like a
diaper is great yeah
thank you I appreciate if you guys want
to buy this heat mist benefit it all
from people buying this personally uh no
but it does help us make videos no sure
you know I don't get a penny off of it
but uh you enjoy seeing that guys pay
Shauna more I mean can we do a patreon
for you personally would they be down
with that of course shot I'm gonna keep
my mouth shut there's always a minefield
for me yeah yeah but I appreciate I
appreciate that I wish that you were I'm
gonna pay start setting a check every
month you keep going oh yeah I'm not
good at expressing it but my mouth is
burning right now actually less seems
like in really bad shape
you went for the second bite and I think
it's about the art print for the art by
the way now I'm totally fine yeah
should we try you got a you got a book
one time I I'm always on the fence about
telling you have it's still in the side
here no I'll just say I'll give a little
anecdote one time I walked around all
day with a big book hanging and a friend
said to me and it's always an awkward
thing to be like hey you have a book
hanging but a friend said to me you've
got a book hanging and I was so grateful
that he phoned me right I like to be
respected share cuz if I saw that book
hang and I didn't say anything that's
kind of [ __ ] up right what you're just
avoiding the conflict but you're not
being a good friend
no you're not you're out you
No so if you so moral of this whole
interview if you see a friend and he's
got a bug hang and be a good friend and
Tommy's got a bug hanging right that's
tomorrow I'm not even the one is anyone
up for it now you're gonna make me try
don't nobody here is is well this is les
right well party no I know
I'd say about it I think that confirm
that I think that if you have 10 people
and you try both sauces I think half of
the people tell you that the pepper X
version is hotter and maybe half you
know it's just one of those things like
once you're in like who's the better yes
yes boy it's like who's better Steph
Curry or James Harden or LeBron James
like eventually brought down our space
yeah like throwing hot ones now if you
like so is one two three four five
Eli do you want one I don't yeah I don't
wanna you know [ __ ] your life up we're
moving this weekend so I'm gonna need
your help yeah abled bodied so people so
you were out here in LA shooting so did
you feel I'm going you know I was
hanging out with Phil Edie yesterday
that's so good he made it on the he's a
friend of the show Greg yeah he's it's
such a great guy you don't have to eat
that but I am absolved of all sorry what
were you saying Phil Edie friend his
show great guy yeah yes I was that
Philly mm-hm
what's behind that door jumped up don't
don't take one I see your hesitation
yeah was uh went over to Philly dhq and
I did an interview with him like for his
show and then he went and did hot ones
with us the old switcheroo
old switcheroo I love it I'm looking
forward to that so you filmed it
yesterday
yep so how long does it take to actually
produce that so you know as you know
with like somebody else like crank this
out
like a lot of coordination that happens
you're doing it live but it's like you
know we'll have to hit like a peg on a
movie or this on an album release or
whatever so it's like maybe you shoot
something a month before it ends up
hitting the website maybe you sure maybe
four it hits the YouTube page
maybe you shoot something eight days
before it hits like our fastest
turnaround ever is a week and that's
like really yeah
that's like us being aggressive as
possible it would be like we shoot it on
Thursday
publish it on Thursday no yeah you've
done that yeah we've done that a couple
times
wait you shot and posted the same day no
no no a week oh let's take a bite let's
take a bite I want the next one okay you
well okay you might as well in my
opinion a little bite is as bad as she's
taking all of it but maybe I'm wrong I
don't trust you I don't trust you did
you correct me if I'm wrong is that all
right
it made my brain go deep like when you
said that so now this one yeah
I like the other one actually about to
be more flavorful
it's a Maxwell Wow that one's more
[ __ ] up I feel yeah immediately yeah
maybe it's cuz I've already been in that
other one tastes better I do like but
this one is like it kind of like a deer
immediately I'm having flashbacks so
yeah they're not that one although those
dabs were larger there are very
aggressive dabs all those are aggressive
as a [ __ ] around try to make up Melissa
so tell me about your family because a
week to edit an interview seems like a
lot from where I come from but we're
very yeah but we get small operation
there's like a whole thing where you
have a whole score to it you know like
we're not ones like right right you know
so like it'll be like a whole thing you
know you'll take this hour and 10-minute
interview you'll like
what I'll do is uh go in with an editor
and then we'll like cut it down to like
just the content so you're involved in
the editing process
yeah like down to picking them you're on
the top you d you focus on all the
details you're involved there's no part
of the sandwich that I'm not involved
with like we have an amazing editor and
I want to shout out Chris Murphy cuz
he's an unsung all this so the editing
is great yeah so Chris Murphy love you
buddy and he's an amazing editor but
yeah like from the research to the wings
no no to top me off boy to uh to every
aspect like picking music and cutting
angles and everything yeah like I'm
involved in all of it I can't give it up
I'm like so obsessed with it no the milk
really knows and I heart is like good
like the Reaper was way harsher on
initial intake but it has it's fallen
off the pepper I would say that that's
actually it is that's that's true like
if that's the correct assessment that's
a correct assessment it's a yin yang you
have a situation with those two the
pepper X that that crept up yeah I had a
second I was like that wasn't bad at all
in a minute later I'm dying
it has like a late wave creep and like
Ian to cos the taste is kind of Pleasant
at first yeah feels like I was teabag by
Satan it looks like you were teabag by
saying do the fans know that you're so
involved in the whole crew do they see
you as the host or they like this is his
show you know some people don't even
think I'm writing questions and yeah you
know like people which actually gives a
compliment because it's like Oh Sean's
like so [ __ ] handsome and a like
that I always like that's usually people
like trying to take a shot at me but I'm
always like thank you like I really
appreciate right right but yeah there's
like there's no there's no part of it
that I'm not touching and I which suck
it which actually like is not a good
thing I'm like no it is a good thing if
you want to know what's going on all day
I mean on that that's probably a big
reason why it's so quality why the
quality has been there from the
beginning and and persists well because
yeah you know like in that way you know
it won't because I won't let it like it
won't dip because I just won't let it
so there's that far but then it is you
know obviously such a labor-intensive
show that sometimes you think like maybe
can't grow outside of it because you're
so in the weeds on every single part you
know I took yeah that's also true I mean
in our case for example we're doing like
the Teddy fresh the broadcast and the h3
and sometimes I feel like I try to work
too much on everyone and get torn right
but at least you got at least you got
three guys here yeah
you know they help keep that tent up no
the trust these guys you like these guys
they're the greatest they're the
greatest and everyone smile I just got
to bring them out here and tour today I
want to say thank you Sean Evans so much
for coming out thank you for you are the
greatest you are appreciated you are
loved thank you dude is there anything
that you want to tell the people you do
this whole thing like hey what are you
promoting wouldn't work you know hot
ones be really careful about shredder by
the way okay
subscribe to first we feast if you like
the shows if you like the episodes it's
it's hot once it's Sean in the wild it's
the burger show we have food skills and
food grills and more amazing things on
the way so first we feast you know it's
not just hot ones I really think that
you know we check a lot of boxes with
that and there's a lot of dope [ __ ] to
check out so if you're bored you're
looking for an internet rabbit hole to
go down suggest that one I also highly
suggest it isn't it's the best coming in
two guys
I agree well that's nice yeah you guys
can subscribe to our channel for free do
you know that free money does exist it
does I'm telling you if you connect your
twitch Prime account strike that if you
can go necked your Amazon Prime account
to twitch you could subscribe every
month for free it's free money you if
you can't support our sponsors or do
bite shirts or any [ __ ] and you want
to self support us connect the account
it's free okay thank you god bless next
week we have deadmau5 joining us please
leave your questions on the server and I
want to say if you guys are looking for
updates about when we are going live who
our guests is up whatever updates if
we're late for early follow the h3
podcasts on Twitter for all future
updates or follow me on instagram and
h3h3 productions that's it thank you
again and hope to see you again soon
buddy yeah guys thank you all so much
for watching hope you'll have a great
weekend it's already the weekend
Saturday our whole weekend so we're
we're gonna do it on Friday your
schedule no it's fine it's flexible I
think it's our first weekend show though
just coincidentally don't have been on
where it's been like all week has been
weird all right thanks Thank You lovey I
appreciate you you got it got it
[Music]
[Applause]